In this lecture, we start
our systematic
study of Bayesian inference.
We will first talk a little
bit about the big picture,
about inference in general,
the huge range of possible
applications, and the different
types of problems
that one may encounter.
For example, we have hypothesis
testing problems in
which we are trying to choose
between a finite and usually
small number of alternative
hypotheses or estimation
problems where we want to
estimate as close as we can an
unknown numerical quantity.
We then move into the
specifics of Bayesian inference.
The central idea is that we
always use the Bayes rule to
find the posterior distribution
of an unknown
random variable based on
observations of a related
random variable.
Depending on whether the random
variables are discrete
or continuous, we must of course
you use the appropriate
version of the Bayes rule.
If we want to summarize the
posterior in a single number,
that is, to come up with a
numerical estimate of the
unknown random variable, we
then have some options.
One is to report the
value at which the
posterior is largest.
Another is to report the
mean of the conditional
distribution.
These go under the acronyms
MAP and LMS.
We will see shortly what these
acronyms stand for.
Given any particular method
for coming up with a point
estimate, there are certain
performance metrics that tell
us how good the estimate is.
For hypothesis testing problems,
the appropriate
metric is the probability of
error, the probability of
making a mistake.
For problems of estimating
a numerical quantity, an
appropriate metric that we will
be using a lot is the
expected value of the
squared error.
As we will see, there will be
no new mathematics in this
lecture, just a few definitions,
a few new terms,
and an application of
the Bayes rule.
Nevertheless, it is important to
be able to apply the Bayes
rule systematically and
with confidence.
For this reason, we will be
going over several examples.